this is the declaration of results of
poll the election of a member of
parliament for Peterborough I take it
over the right wishful mayor of the city
of Peterborough being the returning
officer of the above election do hereby
give notice that the number of votes
recorded for each candidate but the said
election is as follows i Christopher
David the Liberal Party 639 Bisbee boy
Darren Charles the Green Party 1218 Paul
restrain Labour Party
16700 power Darren Liberal Democrats
1774
John Raymond independent 516 Perkin
married UK Independence Party you get
seven thousand two hundred eighty-five
Jaxon Stewart James the Conservative
Party candidates eighteen thousand
18600 makes bull and I do hereby declare
but Stewart James Jackson is duly
elected as Member of Parliament for the
Pittsburgh constituents
Thank You mr. mayor my gratitude to the
efficient way that the City Council
staff that undertaken this is canvas and
also the way that finishing this tableau
in their customary way have efficiently
policed the camp today massive honor and
privilege to have been elected and
re-elected three times whether people
the city of Peterborough and for me
there is no better honor than to
represent my fellow citizens in the
muzzle of Parliament and lots of
comments I like to pay tribute to my
fantastic when plaintively
my loyal agent Matthew doctor my
hard-working chairman
everyone else helped in this campaign
you know but again my thanks my warmest
thanks my most sincere thanks to my
wonderful loyal wife salmon rumors of my
political death will be greatly
exaggerated five days ago
hoon asked of me maybe to look at
polling methodology predicted I was dead
and buried and my political career was
over this was we don't know any media
locally and nationally
well I'm not been buried I'm Lazarus and
back
and well it's sad that the labor policy
is that negative
they have taken on both the fact they
tried to buy this
the query sitting fantastic future mucho
finish place a selfie champagne 50,000
I didn't community to the labor party
you had a clue there might explain to
your account